Everything would change again
and some of those changes may be sh*te
and we may make the same mistakes again
it won't be perfect
But it'll be alongside better than what we
got now
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my justice league dark
apocalypse war
movie video a lot of you requested i
make a video for this probably one of
the best animated movies that dc has
ever done
it's also the last dc animated movie as
part of this line of continuity so i'll
explain how that works
with all the easter eggs and what was
going on with that ending if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing a
giveaway for copies of the blu-ray for
the movie all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the movie on the video
obviously careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the movie yet
there's a lot of easter eggs here so
i'll number these as we go along but a
lot of you may have also noticed that
the plot of this animated movie is based
on the cancelled plans for the original
live-action justice league trilogy that
zack snyder was doing
i'll explain that during the video too
so we'll just start at the beginning and
work our way through
the movie itself is kind of like dc
animations version of avengers infinity
war
and avengers end game wrapped up into
the same movie you probably saw a lot of
similarities with the plot of infinity
war the snap
in an end game with all the time travel
the reason why they started with the
quote from the flash
flashpoint movie is made clear in the
ending scene with that tag from
constantine where he says okay we can
change some things
some things are going to be worse in the
new timeline some things will be better
but we understand that
when i say this is the last movie though
in this line of continuity it all
started with justice league war the
flashpoint movie which they referenced a
couple times during this movie the flash
is i know you don't all believe me about
the flashpoint event that i told you a
while ago
but dc makes a lot of animated movies
they'll continue to make a lot of
animated movies it's just not all of
them will be connected to these movies
there have been a certain line of movies
that have been connected to each other
if you didn't notice
like the last movie before this this
sort of connects with things was the
reign of the supermen
but this picks up in the events right
after that post-credit scene from the
reign of the superman
with superman telling the justice league
that after darkseid's multiple failed
attempts to conquer earth starting with
justice league war and more recently
during reign of the supermen darkseid
was behind the hank henshaw plot they
changed the plot from the comic book
reign of the superman a little bit
superman tells them they need to go to
apocalypse to defeat darkseid on his
home turf rather than waiting for him to
come attack earth again
what they don't realize though is that
darkseid has secretly been using the
motherbox tech that cyborg is made of
to spy on them so he knows they're
coming he's prepared he's hybridized his
parademons using doomsday's dna
to make super parademons that he calls
paradums and i love the way they opened
the movie with them flying through the
boom tube that cyborg has created with
his boo-yah
but then they cut to two years later and
everything has just gone to complete
hell
later in the movie they sort of give you
flashbacks explaining what happened to
all the heroes how things went so
terrible
the justice league got their asses
handed to them by darkseid because he
knew they were coming he injected
superman with liquid kryptonite
stripping him of his powers
bonding to his dna so that it wouldn't
just burn out of his system quickly
he dismantles cyborg replacing his
mother box tech with apocalyptian father
box tech
fully taking control of him effectively
turning him into a hardcore
security system he mind controls batman
forces him to become his servant and
gives him the mobius chair to fly around
doing his bidding he turns wonder woman
martian manhunter hawkman
mira in starfire into cyborgs making
them his new mechanized furies
the only reason lex luthor survives is
because he agrees to be their pawn
on earth their representative the new
gods reporting to the mind controlled
batman and dark side because dark side
is basically going to mine earth for all
of its resources
most of the other heroes get killed
including zatanna who's important for
constantine's storyline remember this is
justice league dark apocalypse war but
it's
basically a crossover of a bunch of
different franchises
justice league dark because of the
constantine the magic based stuff the
regular justice league stuff
teen titans because of all the damian
wayne raven stuff and then you also have
the suicide squad team with them later
zatanna gets killed by the pair dooms
constantine flees back to planet earth
feeling completely guilty feeling like
he abandoned everyone abandoned her
later he finds out that's not actually
true the reason why he fled back to
earth had something to do with satana
that i'll explain in a second
but two years go by darkseid has fully
conquered the planet
everything has gone to complete crap the
surviving justice league and teen titans
characters
team up with the suicide squad who
survived amanda waller
she died off they want to go back to
apocalypse to kill darkseid once and for
all
but when they arrive darkseid is still
off-planet trying to conquer owa the
home of the green lantern corps because
this is all about
conquering the entire universe remember
we're talking thanos level
infinity war avengers endgame they're
met by darkseid's justice league furies
that have been turned into cyborgs but
they're able to free wonder woman from
his mind control using the lasso of
truth and then slowly start to free the
other heroes from his control
they find out what happened to the flash
darkseid has been keeping him trapped on
an apocalyptian version of the cosmic
treadmill
using him as a generator to power the
entire planet
they free him cyborg frees the rest of
the justice league hybrid furies from
their mind control
and then they're forced to release
trigon from his magical prison the dark
sides put him in in order to ultimately
defeat darkseid
but this isn't the end of things going
completely off the rails
because constantine is trying to make
amends for what he feels like was his
failure
during their first big fight he offers
himself as trigon's host because in
order for trigon to
exist in our reality he has to have a
host body
normally that would be raven's sacrifice
to make but constantine is like no it'll
be me
trigon however decides to inhabit
superman's body who's still
consumed with the kryptonite blood so he
doesn't have his powers but now he's a
hybrid version of trigon superman
he instantly revenge kills constantine
because trigon hates constantine
then while he's in the afterlife
constantine learns from the dead
zatanna's spirit that she actually used
her magic
two years ago in order to force him to
run away from the battle
is part of batman's grand contingency
plan
because of course batman would have a
contingency plan knowing that they might
lose and it would lead to some darkest
timeline
you find out back on earth lois lane is
part of an underground fight club with
harley quinn and the rest of the suicide
squad harley quinn has taken over
leadership of the suicide squad because
amanda waller has died
lois and the suicide squad sacrificed
themselves to destroy
all the pair of dooms and the boom tube
that lex luthor has been controlling
watching her die is what frees superman
from trigon's control he's able to expel
his spirit from his body
and because he'd been possessed with the
power of trigon once he separates from
his spirit the kryptonite in his system
has been burned off so he gets his
powers back finally
he manages to fight darkseid to a
standstill keeping him busy but he's
still not powerful enough
that's when they unleash trigon on him
and they battle it out for supremacy of
the universe while the two gods
effectively are beating the cosmic crap
out of each other cyborg
boom tubes everyone back to earth and
then sacrifices himself by creating an
artificial black hole that sucks
everything the entire planet of
apocalypse
along with darkseid trigon and himself
into it
implying that they're taken care of for
a long time as cool as this scene is
a black hole is not powerful enough to
kill trigon or darkseid
it would keep them busy for a long time
trapped but cyborg is definitely
dead back on earth the surviving heroes
lick their wounds and decide that in
order to
fix everything this darkest timeline per
batman's contingency plan
they need the flash to create another
flash point going back in time to change
the past and
warn the justice league of the past
giving them maybe a chance of fighting
darkseid or a better chance at least
the closing scene they end on is meant
to be a mirror for the flashpoint scene
where he goes back in time to change
everything
they have to talk him into it a little
bit because when he created flashpoint
the first time
it just turned everything into complete
crap so he says i'm never going to do
this again
so they really do have to massage him
just a little bit in order to convince
him that no no no
anything that you create will be better
than this but constantine's speech
sort of brings things back around to the
beginning of the movie in that
flashpoint quote
so the quote itself from flashpoint was
actually something that barry's mother
told him
when he had to understand that he
couldn't save her she was destined to
die it was a fixed point in time
accept the things you cannot change have
the courage to change the things that
you can and have the wisdom to know the
difference
the heroes in the flash by the end of
the movie understand that this new
flashpoint they're creating will be able
to change
some things for the better but not
others some things for better some
things for worse
and they just understand they won't be
able to fix everything but they can fix
most things so they're going to take a
chance and roll the dice on it
i feel like it was an amazing animated
dc movie dc
generally does solid animation work but
in terms of just
capping off this line of continuity it
felt like a really good version of
avengers end game with the dc characters
but here's the thing like i said the
plot of this movie follows a lot of what
their original plans were for zack
snyder's justice league trilogy when
they were still doing a justice league
trilogy
what was going to happen is that in the
first justice league movie events were
relatively similar some of the
characters were changed just a little
bit
but at the end of the movie when
steppenwolf was defeated and gets sucked
back to apocalypse through the boom tube
darkseid was going to appear to them at
the end of the other boomtube they would
see a vision of him so it would be the
teaser that they would fight him in the
next movie
then in justice league 2 the justice
league was going to go to apocalypse to
destroy him just like they do in the
animated movie
they lose hard just like they do in the
animated movie then darkseid comes back
to planet earth conquering it doesn't
this all sound familiar after you watch
the animated movie that would have
created the future that you see
in batman's nightmare scene from batman
v superman
that comes to pass then in justice
league 3
the final movie in the trilogy that
would have been their avengers end game
they send the flash back in time to warn
batman
in a slightly different way than they
had done the first time warning him to
save lois successfully so that he can
prevent superman from being enslaved by
the anti-life equation
obviously that works because it's the
final movie in the trilogy they're able
to defeat
darkseid before this nightmare vision
future can come to pass
creating a new timeline they would have
already introduced hal jordan within the
justice league trilogy in the green
lantern corps so there would have been a
giant space battle going on too in this
just like the ending of avengers end
game with that giant avengers assemble
moment
but as you can see it would have played
out very similarly to avengers infinity
war and avengers end game making
everybody compare
justice league to marvel and even though
it sounds like a really cool
trilogy of movies it would have been a
little bit awkward with the timing
so i think a lot of the inspiration for
this movie came
from that canceled plans of that trilogy
they've been working on this movie for a
couple of years now so it's not like
they copied avengers end game or
anything like that it took them a couple
years to make this
so it was in the works for a long time
everyone let me know in the comments
though what did you think of the movie
and what is your favorite
dc animated movie so far superman red
sun was actually pretty good too but
like i said it's not connected to this
justice league continuity of animated
movies
there's a bunch of stuff that happened
this week the flash finale is next week
there's a whole bunch of animated stuff
that just happened too we had our clone
wars finale
everyone click here for my clone wars
finale video last episode ever
and click here for my flash finale
trailer video thank you so much for
watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!